[Music]
so I've been I've been building
companies for 20 years in Austin Texas
and currently started a company called
WP engine about nine and a half years
ago and we're big users of the cloud as
you're about to see and in particular
we've just transformed our corporate
data and our processes around there
using a technology from Google and some
code of our own which I'm going to show
you both of so hopefully this is useful
to you
so here's we go oh wow your stats are so
big you guys are amazing and successful
I think my favorite one here is 5% of
every human who's online today which is
about 3.5 billion people come to one of
our properties every day and so what we
do is we are the most used and most
popular platform for running WordPress
digital experiences so WordPress being
the open source project that powers one
third of every domain on earth today and
we power a lot of the larger sites that
use WordPress there so that's all cool
and we have lots of we have about a more
than a third of a million sites running
on Google Cloud and also I'm going to
show you this NASCAR slide of all the a
lot of customers and the reason is not
actually not to impress you because
everyone's got you know logos but rather
if in the context of corporate data it's
very easy as engineers to think I know
I'll just grab all the data from all the
places and stick it somewhere and then
we'll make reports duh it's the obvious
thing and there's various reasons why
that's not as simple as what the real
problem is and this is one reason
because a lot of these folks have
requirements on us about what we do with
their data and as you probably know
starting in Europe but now here as well
companies are getting more and more
strict about what their vendors are able
to do what kinds of security practices
you have to have around that whether you
need to do sock to and that sort of
stuff for what and so when we think
about collecting our corporate data
which of course includes our customers
data and kind data about customers we
have to think about what restrictions
are they putting on on us what audits do
they give us because we have to pass
those while still doing what we want to
do with data that actually makes it kind
of hard and again I'm going to show you
how we how we work with through that so
we had a challenge for our cell
recently which is we have about a
hundred thousand customers which is nice
and as we scale and grow the number of
customers everything else scales servers
and difficulties processes and corporate
data so we have this sort of
company-wide mantra of hey how are we
going to support half a million
customers so about 5x where we are today
and I think this is actually an
interesting a pattern to use in general
when thinking about how to plan ahead so
a lot of folks just say well when
something breaks we fix it that's of
course not planning ahead that's being
always behind by definition right then
the other way is to say and as engineers
we like this
what if it's 10 or a hundred times
bigger what what do we need to build and
that's fun because it's fun to think
about how to architect something for
something that large it's also not
necessary you're not going to be a
hundred times bigger any time soon most
things aren't going to be anyway and so
you end up over architecting and so this
kind of rule of thumb of maybe 5x is to
me a nice rule of planning in general
for stuff weather data or otherwise it's
enough in the future that you're looking
ahead but not going crazy no over
architecting stuff so that was sort of
our guiding principle there and so what
we wanted to do is say all right we've
got corporate data what does that mean
it means financial data right off of our
general ledger or the invoices that we
charge customers every month again we
process about 70,000 invoices a month
because a lot of most customers are
month-to-month and then users data about
our user portal there's data on the on
the actual servers we run almost 10,000
servers around the world and so what's
going on there and what's happening
inside our customer sites so we process
about 10 billion web requests a day so
just logging all that sticking it
somewhere which by the way is bigquery
is already a feat and there's all kinds
of interesting stuff in there about
security you know patterns you could
look at for security patterns you could
look at for performance like what could
be cacheable or blocked or something
like this so all kinds interesting stuff
going on there and that's true Big Data
even at Google ten billion thingys a
days is a lot kind of matter who you are
so most of our data of course is not big
data most of anybody's day is not big
data but it's just data and some of its
big so how do we go around
all these systems the web logs the
financial system Salesforce the the
support systems tickets and chats the
our servers how do we take all this data
and put it somewhere that is secure that
we can clean that we can audit that we
can connect that we can give to other
analysts and people in the company for
their various the various reasons why
they care about data how can we do that
that's our that was our question and so
of course I'm going to describe how we
did this this whole time we called it
Grand Central data station because we're
engineers and we're terrible at naming
things and so that's what we called it
anyway so this is what we did it I'm
going to show you some of the how we
wrote some code around this and what it
got us and also how we leveraged tools
from Google to do some of the hard work
for us as well so the first thing is
when you think about a Big Data project
is to define your systems of record
which sounds simple enough it's just
what are where all the places there's
data but it's a little bit more than
that it's where where is their data and
what data does that system actually own
so for example Salesforce for us owns
the sales data it's what the sales folks
do but that's not an N week and we have
customer data in there but that's not
the source of truth for customers that's
not where every that is not the system
that determines what is a customer or
not it determines what the sales person
did which isn't necessarily the same
thing so we even have systems that try
to automate whenever there's a new
customer putting it in Salesforce we
determine later that there are 5,000
incorrect records there because there's
a difference between owning the data and
having a copy of it or having some kind
of notion about it right so it's
important what what are those things so
for us it's these sorts of things and
what does it actually own and defining
that and bringing it in because
ultimately when you put all the data
together of course it's the systems of
records data that's the interesting part
and you might want to push some of that
back out like we do with customer data
back to Salesforce so that the people
who are using the tool have access to it
but it's important to know what's what
and it's not obvious right away what
that is so that's the first thing those
systems have record and then the second
thing is building a place where it can
all come
together so hence the Central Station
and again there's all these challenges
with it the places you're pulling from
each have its own way of authenticating
and have the credentials work so there
has to be a way to securely store that
and still pull it automatically which
I'll describe of course there's
different data formats there's databases
like my sequel and Postgres in our case
and all these systems like Salesforce
Zendesk etc where it might be behind an
API so there's all these different ways
which it comes from and by the way the
reason to solve all this now is because
this is why people can't connect data
today because too hard to grab something
at a Salesforce and something out of
something else and put it together for
any normal person so this is hard but
it's kind of the point
centralization is important too because
there's a lot of insights you can't get
unless you connect data from disparate
sources so you might want to say hey if
we have customers where their traffic is
growing and they're using more and more
of our services and they are either not
contacting support or they have happy
support calls in other words the rating
at high here's a happy growing customer
that might be something a sales person
would want to know right but that
involves connecting stuff from support
and from the farm that which is what we
call our servers and Salesforce what if
we're already talking to them then they
don't need to be on our on a new contact
report
so all these that that's a very basic
example but it shows spanning a whole
bunch of system so centralization is
important and of course the problem
though essential ization is security if
I have everything in my company and a
table in bigquery um whoever has access
to that has access to too much stuff
right certainly violates whatever kind
of policies you might have so it's a
it's a problem so so we centralized the
data when it's centralized and you have
algorithms like cleaning stuff up it's
really nice that everything centralized
because you can run it on everything for
example we have country fields and you
know people use sometimes it's a two
digit code or three digit code or a
fill-in-the-blank like salesforce and we
had people in sales doing this arm
picking on sales a lot but you know
whatever sales force our sales force has
like 300 columns in the accounts table
so there's a lot to make fun of anyway
so so for example in the country field
they would say like London which are
clearly
Mary
who's confused that how countries work
and so there's all this stuff and so
having algorithms that clean it it's
nice to make those tests those and apply
those once and not in all the different
systems of course analyzing and and and
connecting the data and so forth so and
again I'm gonna show you how we did that
with our code and with bigquery and
solved those problems so we got we had a
whole bunch of goals which we succeeded
at and some of them are not obvious so
you know matically of refreshing the
data that's obvious but let me skip down
to like an audit trail where you can
find in an end-user report exactly the
whole trick trail of formulas of where
it came from all the way back to the
original systems of record where the
data really lives
that's something the data analysts never
get or they get documentation of course
gets out-of-date right away so that was
gonna be a really powerful thing if we
could do it which I'll show you
or what's personally identified it
information identifiable information or
PII there's a lot of privacy laws around
things that are PII but if you're an
end-user with a report how do you know
like column three and seven are PII and
you've to be extra careful or they're
not again not something you normally get
so there's some neat stuff I'm gonna
show you that the we were able to
achieve so if it bigquery of course
because I'm standing here so obviously
we use Google stuff there's a couple of
reasons one is as a company that has a
ten thousand servers we know for sure we
do not want more servers we know that
stinks and there's you don't want
service and a lot of these databases
even when they're managed and in fact
even other databases at Google even
though they're managed there's knobs and
things still it's like well you want to
start with three databases all over cuz
high availability in here is how you do
the failover and here's how you might
scale then you got to read through the
disk and just like that's not what I
want to do ever nobody wants to do that
do it for me and one of the great things
about bigquery is it really is that it
really is today I have one rows in a
table and tomorrow I have a trillion
rows and a table and I just pay a little
bit more for storage that's actually how
it works which is really nice again we
have these huge amounts of web logs so
that alone is useful to have something
that scales performance and in big
queries interesting
we can run a query over these logs and
process trillions of rows and summarize
all kinds of stuff and get an
interesting answer in seven seconds also
you can ask it what time it is in a
query and it will also take seven
seconds so I think everything a big
query takes a little bit of time but but
you can kind of ask it as much as you
want that's not completely true if you
stack up queries or you really have a
lot of data it can start slowing down
I'll show you something that we did
about that but in general the
performance for a large amounts of data
is really nice
one area that's not nice is if you have
a report and you're filtering stuff and
changing stuff in each one of those is a
different query because then those seven
seconds makes the iteration time really
slow so that's we're using some kind of
BI tool in front of bigquery is useful
and so in our case we use looker of
course there's a lot of there's a lot of
good once that's just what we happen to
pick and what we found is that it kills
that sort of you might say the
equivalent of the last mile problem of
I'm an end-user looking at a report I
want to quickly look at stuff if you
have a bi tool there it can do that last
mile set of filtering and stuff and that
can be super fast and convenient for
that person and you don't incur the
problems of a big query slowness so
security is another one so I mentioned
this thing where they mention the
security problem of okay I put all my
data in one place and data people call
that a data Lake right which is kinda I
don't know if that's a good analogy a
lake it's kind of a good analogy and
that it's just a whole bunch of stuff
all mixed up and you can't find it
anymore and it's all there I guess but
who knows so I guess it's okay analogy
but anyway when you put all the data
together the good news is you can clean
it and connect it and all that stuff and
the bad news is mmm you kind of want
no-one to have access to it so it's kind
of a kind of a problem so here's what
you can do in bigquery and this is what
we've been doing so you put all the data
somewhere obviously there's a whole
lockdown and almost no one can get to it
maybe service accounts canned so forth
then the marketing department needs some
stuff so what do we do so we create what
is in bigquery called a data set which
is really just like a folder and you can
put stuff in the folder like views and
tables
so in particular we put views in there
so the way it works is marketing we we
figure Oh Marcus um funnel report or
something that they need so if we can
pick all this data out and make some
awesome view that can
all the data one would need for this
report so we take that view when we put
it in a marketing data set then we give
marketing the group access to that
marketing data set and now although
marketing does not have access to the
underlying tables cannot go in there
they are allowed to see what's in the
view so that means really easily like
point-and-click easy we can provide data
sets in the form of views to whomever
have complete access control there of
what and any policies we want about what
we show to whom and how we check that
off or not having much policies
depending on the situation it's very
easy to be flexible there and so we can
we can have the data together create
those those unique reports but then give
people only the resulting report which
they can then take directly they can
take a data studio they can take it to
looker etcetera however it is that they
want to consume it so the the security
model in bigquery that allows us to do
that and use the normal Google users to
do that was extremely convenient for us
to just be able to make these things
easily and not worry too much about
security so that was a that was really
helpful so this is roughly what we built
so we built this system in Python and
the part that's kind of filled in a
little bit is the part that's our Python
code and again I'm going to show you a
little bit about what we did and so the
main thing here because much of this
won't be surprising is just boxes and
arrows with words in the middle that
you've seen before mostly so it's not a
big deal but here's the interesting part
you've seen they're very very front
they're in the data engine it says
specifications in JSON I'm going to
describe this in detail and show you
this is kind of the key that makes this
whole thing work well and if we didn't
do this and we just tried to use
bigquery alone or some bi tool we
wouldn't be able to achieve all those
bullet points on the other page so I'm
gonna explain how we did that but
roughly we especially have a JSON
specifications that say here's how to
pull data from systems of record and
also JSON specifications that say here's
how to transform those that data into
more useable views let me show you that
so from that we can pull from these are
our data sources CMDB bappy these are
these are all own names these are own
internal tools so we're reaching into
things like my sequel and Postgres to
grab stuff out of there and and pulling
that into bigquery and also
we used segment Daioh for some of these
SAS tools that have api's like
salesforce in Zendesk and stripe and i
know today it was just announced there's
even more tools now to automate that
stuff so hooray maybe this is even
easier but anyway we were doing this
just just maybe four months ago segment
was able to handle that and and we have
to handle our own stuff now I think it's
even easier because Google wants you to
put a lot of data in bigquery of course
because then you're paying them more
money and using their stuff of course
don't course it's gonna get more easy to
pull stuff in a big query but that's
good so anyway once it's in there then
the data gets transformed I'm going to
show you that into those reports like I
mentioned and various documentation and
so forth okay so here's an example of a
fraction of JSON hope you can read that
if you can't then it's green text that
looks like JSON then that is about
systems of record so the way it works is
we say all right well here's a table
somewhere here's a here's that here's a
key to the to a credentials file which
of course is elsewhere and not checked
in as you would expect for how to get to
this system and then we define all the
columns with lots of metadata what's the
data type is that null or not is this a
primary key for the table
humans description a human description
like in just regular prose of what this
is and also possibly some metadata like
what is the quality of this data is this
PII
some of those things that I mentioned
earlier we can tag them in here just by
saying it's true or giving it a number
so by doing this already what we can do
is automate the sucking of the data out
of the systems of record and stuffing
them into bigquery so what we do is we
say okay every time we we retrieve the
data we want to get the data we haven't
seen yet so we do that by looking at the
primary keys and saying well whatever
we've gotten up to whatever date
anything that's newer than that will
take as well as if the data is equal
then whatever's newer than the prime the
last primary key on that date that we
got so you know where it's tie goes to
the primary key so by doing that we can
incrementally update as often as we want
at the moment it's every hour but um you
know it's easy to do that
the other thing we can do is validate
the data so if we say in here it can be
null
fine but if we say in here it can't the
data cannot be null but we see one come
through we can flag it we can decide not
to do it we can we can stall we can let
it in anyway and emit a warning whatever
is the way that you want to handle that
is fine but we're able to check and and
sort of validate the data on the way in
from the system of record which might be
dirty there's more things that this can
do what you'll see next so this is an
example of JSON which looks just like
the other JSON if you can't see it which
is a transformation and here the JSON is
it got the structures which looks a lot
like a sequel query so there's a sources
in there which is like a join it says
here's different tables I want to pick
from maybe some join keys some columns I
may want to inherit from that table and
also here's some columns I want to
compute and this one there's one called
is fraud and there's an expression in
there which look if you look at it looks
sort of like like Lisp or something
function argument argument argument
maybe arguments have functions too like
Lisp right in other words like a parsed
tree that's what it looks like so here
we're checking whether some possibly
null field and a fraud table is either
the word fraud or the word banned and if
so then that means it's a boolean is
fraud and bla bla bla this kind of basic
stuff that you do when you clean data or
calculate stuff
there's also filters which look sort of
like a where clause in sequel write only
should only the rows which match this
and so forth and all these expressions
are sitting there in JSON so of course
you might think well this is dumb just
write sequel like this is a lot more
verbose what are you doing and so what
we're doing is actually getting a whole
lot of neat benefits by doing this so
one of the things we can do this Python
that reads in the JSON of course one of
the things that can do is make the
sequel that makes this view and bigquery
and stick it in bigquery which of course
we do so duh other things that can do is
check our own errors are the data types
right are we handling nulls correctly so
all these kinds of things that can be
wrong this code can detect it first off
so that we don't just sort of
accidentally find it later
sometimes databases will complain
sometimes they won't it was sort of
proceed and that's not good we want to
catch
we want to be extra pedantic here we
want this to be like extra lended extra
careful here because data is so
important it is important to get
everything exactly right in this use
case so we don't want to be sloppy at
all
or things that are convenient so for
example maybe I'm concatenated a string
together and in sequel all those things
have to be strings already but we can
say oh look your concatenated strings
oh look that one's a number yeah that's
cool well we'll just throw the the cast
operator in there for you when we make
the sequel you don't need to do that
that's just bother so there's various
things in sequel which can be annoying
which we can actually just clean up and
hide I'll give you an example there's a
really fancy way in bigquery where you
can refer to things like the previous
row which is kind of weird right you're
emitting things and you can ask about
the previous or even the next one that
hasn't been emitted yet it's pretty cool
because all kinds of really neat
calculations running sums or numbering
things a certain way all cuz n neat
things you can do if you can reach
forward and backward a little bit and do
stuff you can do that in bigquery but
the expressions are confusing they can
be a little kind of long just to do that
and especially someone who understands
enough sequel to want to do that and
write this kind of thing but doesn't
understand enough to get into the
windowing systems and analytic functions
in bigquery which are confusing so we
can provide a function called like next
or previous and you just say I want the
next field that next field of this and
it turns into this big query expression
and thanks big worry for being able to
do that that's cool but thanks to this
the operator does not know how not have
to know how to do that correctly we can
generate that confusing thing for the
operator so that's that's nice because
we can do relatively complex things that
don't look so complex when you're
writing it so even just making the
sequel there's advantages here the next
thing though is what else can we do now
that we have all this metadata about it
so one of the things that kind of
classically classically annoying about
them about data is documentation you've
got have good Doc's because the end
users are not programmers general
that could be analysts or even someone
just looking at a report who's not even
an analyst and you want to document
stuff like how this came to be or what
these fields mean or allow someone to
audit it especially in finance you have
audits and so you need you need that
traceability of where this data comes
from especially if you're gonna use it
in a financial context and and your
company gets to a certain scale you must
be able to have an audit or trace of
where that came from so you have
documentation we know how that goes code
and documentation being separate that
means they never match and then you
don't know what's going I like this
course that's how it works
but not here because our documentation
is completely generated only from all
that JSON and so the documentation and
the queries are never different so
here's an example of something that our
documentation creates so this is a tree
of how a certain table called the ledger
which is used by Finance gets created
and so you can see here in purple are
the systems of record tables and in
yellow are these transformations and
then finally the table now of course
there's individual documentation for
every one of these steps but right away
you can see as an N usually oh this is
complicated and you get a sense of what
goes into what and so if you are
auditing if you are trying to figure it
out you have a map at least of this very
complicated thing you least have a map
of what's going on which is already
helpful this by the way is created using
something called graphviz and if you
haven't seen it it's one of these tools
that are like 20 years old but but most
people haven't still don't know about it
it's really cool you can just say things
like this node goes into that one and
this one goes into that one and it lays
it out like this and then you can say oh
also this one has a yellow background so
actually this is real easy you can do it
on the command line this is with a
Python client wrapper so this is this
whole thing just takes something like
ten lines of code total because we just
look through the JSON and how do we tell
the dependencies because we have the
joins since we have the joins we can
just walk them and that's the
dependencies it's actually pretty easy
and then we feed it into this graph it
graph is and just give it arrows and so
this is like almost no code to crap out
this ping and so we do this on every
single table automatically we have this
nice map another example so we have
hyperlinked HTML documentation on every
single column in every single table in
the whole system which would really suck
to have to do by hand I don't have any
tech writers you'd need and what you'd
have to bribe afford it that's kind of
sit through it but anyway so this is
just two examples of what this looks
like so if you look here on the left I
know it's gonna be a little bit hard to
read what we're doing is is saying quite
a few things about the data so I'm like
I'll walk you through some of it so if
you look on the left of the left column
where it says agency natural sales team
what we're doing here is saying hey for
a given agency that we work with there's
some sales team where because of their
geographic location they're the natural
sales team to have this agency which may
not be the same thing as the sales team
that actually has the agency this is the
kind of detailed data stuff that's
actually really helpful without a
complex system it's hard to get this
kind of data so it says that it's not
null over there in the corner which is
nice if you're making reports and it
says data quality 70% where did that
come from so again we can annotate
fields and say what the data quality is
all back in the in this system of record
area so then the transformation JSON you
can imagine saying alright if we know
that you picked this expression and this
one and this one and this one and added
them and one of them has a lower data
quality then the result has a lower data
quality and of course you could argue
about if two of them have load and they
multiply or just the lowest you know you
could argue about how to how data
quality should be measured and how that
should progress whatever the point is
you could pick and decide how that works
and so in the end result we can see it's
not that good and the reason it's not
that good is this data comes from that
thing I told you about earlier where
people put in strange data and so this
is okay but not great also we imported
data from a data source that we bought
and we know that data source is about
70% right we were able to write all that
in in the in the original data sources
so that later when someone's computing
this thing this is a fairly complicated
thing that just shows up and again a
human doesn't have to maintain that it
just shows up and it's in the
documentation so the next thing it does
is again there's people who write sequel
and that's probably the people on this
and then for everybody that writes
sequel there's 10 or or maybe even 50
other people at the company who need to
consume it and don't know sequel so the
other thing we do is rewrite out in kind
of English ish what is the formula which
if you think about it if you have the
expression it's not that hard just to
format that thing and as HTML instead of
format again s equal so in this case if
this condition holds then we use this
value a switch you know sort this is a
switch statement right okay so the thing
on the left if the first value matches
any of these so that's an in right like
it's not this isn't rocket science about
how this is working this is fit straight
forward but by doing that you can see by
using by using bullets we can indent
them so if it gets complicated that can
just match it can match this sort of
indentation you would see in code
matches that with bullets so you see
that all kind of works out okay and in
fact this is a complex formula that that
is actually kind of hard to read even in
code and this is kind of nice
but this is something that an analyst
can read without knowing sequel okay if
one of these I see all Australia stuff
there then it's Australian New Zealand
gotcha okay if if they're in the US but
also if they're in one of these states
in the US or later on it says it were
maybe they're in Canada etc then they're
in the North America East group so but
if I'm in sales and I'm going wait a
minute how did you decide who's in North
America East it's super easy to just go
see that and if it's wrong by the way
easy to see and go tell the developer Oh
wrong you know this this cities supposed
to be in the other thing and very easy
for the developer to fix but without
that good luck ever finding that you're
gonna maybe find it very hard but just
by making it easier to read and because
we have the stuff in the JSON format
super easy to make those otherwise that
would be hard so the stuff on the right
is more like for auditing so this is
just different tabs that we have in the
in the HTML and this one we call origins
and the idea is our I've got I've got an
expression and weird what are all the
systems of records and all the fields in
those systems of records that were
touched in the making of this final
result recursively like everywhere what
touched so it's just a big old list sort
of sorted by where it came from that's
big ol list so that mean that may not
seem that useful as an engineer because
it's useful to not flatten things out
for engineer it's good to chunk things
but if you're an auditor this is great
are you sure PII wasn't used in the
making of this field well that's all the
data that was used making the field so
if one of these needs to be PII we can
go mark it and then this will say PII no
problem but but on the other hand if
this is all clean an order to can go
yeah right this is all clean we're good
again it's an honor this is huge and if
you're in finance if the auditor is
happy and you're happy that's it and
even as a developer the auditor comes to
you and says you need to document this
and explain that that's annoying to be
able to hand this over and say let me
know if you have any questions is
awesome as an engineering you don't have
to do that yourself so it may not seem
kind of amazing but it it is for these
use cases for data so then so then not
everyone wants to consume sequel
actually a lot of data analysts nowadays
do want to consume sequel directly and
that's great and so for those that don't
we wanted to pick a standardized tool
for the company for people to build
reports in and such when you pick looker
I mean there's obviously a lot of good
ones to pick from nowadays and
everybody's gonna integrate with
bigquery which is nice it's another
reason to pick one of the winners in the
data warehousing world to maximize your
options for integrations so we pick
looker the there's a couple of reasons
just if you're curious why we didn't
pick that and like it's not like we I
don't really care which you pick on that
ceiling for looker but in case this is
useful to you
looker caches data and that means it's
both faster for the end user and cheaper
because that bigquery of course charges
for storage which generally isn't that
much unless you have all the records
that we have and for query time and so
if you cache and that means you're even
less worried about what Google's
charging you another thing is looker
makes it very easy to build reports in
which you can filter and double-click
and there's something people love about
being able to drill down by
double-clicking they love the drill down
and look I don't know that
makes it it makes it easy people love
that stuff the other thing is whatever
you're looking at it looker with all the
filters and the drill downs and the
things is all in the get URL so you can
just bookmark or throw that URL at
somebody or whatever and they can leap
right into that particular thing and
that's not true of some of these other
tools
that's just so handy and practice to be
able to do that or if you're building
dashboards so you know I I'm an analyst
tonight I have a3 dashboards I build for
my little my function I mean for me to
be able to just say oh I'll have three
tabs and each one is just this URL and
updating what's in it is just updating
the URL how easy is this it's super easy
or people on their laptops could just
bookmark a URL it's just it becomes
really easy to do also all the things
that are in there are in bed Abul so for
example there's a lot of this kind of
data we wanted to put into salesforce
into the UI of salesforce because if
you're in the sales team you live in
salesforce you don't want to live in
salesforce and some reporting tool and
be jumping around that's not good
so with looker we're able to take these
take these reports or charts or whatever
kinds of things and just a little piece
like one chart with this filter on it of
the past week or whenever and you can
embed that right into the dashboard in
salesforce with with no code and
salesforce and no special crap no
special add-ons you can just embed it
again in part because of this deep
linking that goes right in so that means
we're able to build the sales team I
should say the sales ops team is able to
build dashboards in Salesforce for the
reps and the managers they never have to
leave Salesforce to get this data which
is awesome again that's that's looker
but they still have the double-click so
if they go well what about this bullet
now they're now they're in looker and
they can go play so it's just again a
really nice thing for people and these
again as engineers sometimes you think
of this like who cares like so it's
embedded in this dashboard instead of
that winner so what you can click on it
doesn't sound like a big deal but in
practice especially for non-technical
people the idea that it's just there and
I can click and get more is actually a
really big usability factor and that's
what this part of the system should be
about is usability for the folks that
need to use the data so that's that's
what we picked
so a couple of things um it was harder
to it was harder to connect to all the
systems of record than we thought even
with even with things like segments we
actually had to file and get some bugs
fixed from segment just to get our
Salesforce data to work so it wasn't
easy we also ran into some trickiness
with secrets so for example we used
Apache airflow to create a work flow
around around how to pull all this data
so in other words you know pull it from
all these systems and then make these
transformations and then these and an
old series we use the patchy airflow
it's a workflow system for defining
those and doing it once again how do we
create that those rules we've got it
from the JSON and we spit it out and it
goes right into air flow and Google has
a managed air flow by the way which we
use and then it runs those things on
kubernetes so then we were able to use
the kubernetes secrets system to
actually take all those secrets to all
those systems which of course those are
crown jewel secrets so that's really
careful
our financial data our customer data
this is a scary stuff but by being able
to put it into the vault in kubernetes
and letting it run in there it's a nice
safe way where no human being ever gets
their mitts on those secrets and yet you
know we can automate the pulling of all
the data so that's that's really nice so
it was hard to get that to work actually
um it was non-trivial to figure out how
to get multiple things into the vault
how to make sure the kubernetes got the
stuff out of the vault these things were
not easy for us to get up and running at
first but but once they were running
it's now been running for maybe three
and a half months with not one problem
no maintenance issue no no nothing at
all so that's that's really good so so
overall overall it was really good even
though it was a it was a challenge to
get going it's still it's still
difficult to this day to understand what
data is right and I think even though
we've built a lot of systems for that
it's it's still hard so for example
we'll pull data from our general ledger
we'll pull data from stripe where we run
the credit card side of the business and
from the user portal where we show
invoices and then it'll be customers
where that stuff doesn't match you say
okay but all this stuff is supposed to
be right and at that point Google can't
help you and JSON can't help you
so just running through all that has
taken and we continue to work on that
stuff today it has taken a lot more time
than expected then than we expected when
we've talked to other folks even in the
even in the server business about
billing and those kinds of areas we
discovered that Google has this problem
Amazon has this problem
Rackspace had this problem actually
billing turns out to be really hard but
who knew but actually it's really hard
so at least though we have a system
where it's easy for us to understand
what it is that we are doing in the
first place and therefore maybe iterate
and diagnose the other thing we did is
we made test obviously unit test
integration test everybody knows that so
of course we did that the other thing
that we did is these Spock check smoke
tests so what we do is we'd say we
discover some customer with weird data
and so okay what we we would create a
CSV file of the rate of the result of
some report against that customer that
was actually right and that became a
test right so every time we update all
the corporate data we'll run this
particular report and check it against
the test CSV to make sure that we didn't
break that so it's like an integration
test in that it's a end-to-end test but
it's on the actual production data so
it's like a third level of tests we of
course in those we have to be careful
just to read and validate and never
change anything unlike an integration
test or you're allowed to change the
state because you can reset it so by
having just the system and we've
probably all built these kinds of things
where you can drop a CSV file somewhere
and drop a query somewhere and add a
test easily because of that we've been
able to add about a hundred tests which
doesn't sound like a lot but it's you
know we have maybe five or six hundred
unit tests but we were able to add an
end-to-end test so now even when we find
something really strange in boundary and
we make a little change to the JSON
we're very confident after it gets
deployed that we haven't broken anything
in the other crazy cases that we've seen
right so taking the time to build those
in production tests that has been that
has been useful in this other problem so
we've changed we've changed things as a
result these are some of them I'll give
you a funny example you would think that
the number of customers we have is not a
debatable or difficult concept but
actually is turns out and
everybody has a different number for how
many customers we have and this is
solved that just by normalizing what we
call a customer so for example in
finance if someone comes in on April the
10th and leaves on April the 12th and we
give them a refund as we do then as far
as GAAP is concerned no money happened
no money changed hands in total and so
this is a no op and so it's not a
customer
so finance that doesn't count that as a
customer for the month in support that's
not how they view it and support civil
came in and called them so obviously
it's a customer I talk to them
what's the vendor customer who else was
I talking to so it counts and so when
supports thinking okay I'm trying to do
capacity planning and hiring planning
and how many customers we get a month
and therefore how many people I need in
blah blah blah and we have about 250 or
300 people in support so this planning
is important and getting the details
right is important because it's a lot of
folks that we might need to hire they
need to count that it's a customer
they're not going to get their hiring
plan right and similarly finance needs
to I guess not count them as a customer
so that we're correct with GAAP so the
point being by sort of forcing ourselves
to see all of the stuff even different
definitions of the same concept like a
customer it forced us to go okay what do
we really mean by this what do we need
to mean we might need the concept of a
GAAP customer or a real customer we
might need different words even and with
all the data in one place we can produce
all of those numbers so we can be so
everyone get the data that they actually
need but we can we can actually
normalize what we're talking about so if
you think it's bad for customer you can
imagine things that are less less simple
how confusing that was getting so anyway
so it's helped us normalize how we talk
about things and report on things which
has been really nice and other things
like this okay well I guess we'll call
it that thanks everybody thanks for your
time
[Music]